first question maybe for Ridley is how
do you see the Martian sort of fitting
into your sort of larger kind of sci-fi
sci-fi films well the challenge is you
know sci-fi mostly as fantasy what was
really attractive about this is the
total reality of the situation I think I
mentioned earlier there was a film I was
quite liked I liked a lot actually call
the right stuff which kind of got into
the early days of the astronauts and and
I thought this was it not the same at
all but I loved the reality of the
situation the challenges that an
astronaut may have in how long 15 years
20 years and and Fermat you know
obviously Mark Watney kinda has a
personality in the book and you know how
was it to kind of bring that to life and
what specific sort of aspects of his
personality kind of drew you to to
taking on this character don't ask him
that sorry too much well I think a lot
of people including myself really
responded to the character in the book
that and II wrote and and Drew Goddard
our screenwriter I thought did a great
job of capturing that and so yeah it's
like being a chef and getting a really
good piece of meat to cook you know you
don't want them you don't want to
overthink it and mess it up too much and
bronze the gold medal so I just tried to
kind of keep alive what what Andy had
created were there parts of the book
that you sort of drew order to and kind
of wanted to bring to life and sort of
put that voice you know into the
character as well well I think the the
the humor and though and the way that I
think was kind of mere mortals are
always captivated by the way people can
do this and seem to have some
preternatural calm when they're in these
incredibly high stress situations and
and and that was what was really
attractive about the character how he
kept his sense of humor and and and then
you and and keep this incredible logical
kind of practical solve one problem at a
time type of thinking and and and it's
what these real guys can actually do
it's amazing I'm sitting next to one of
them so yeah actually
you know - for you you know like seeing
that you know what is it is it kind of
interesting to sort of want to see the
an astronaut character like that brought
to life and have him be sort of more of
a human character than what they are I
thinking a lot of folks yeah I mean it
was for me it's I've read the book one
and a half times I tried to read it a
second time before showing up here today
just to get caught up again but it's
amazing you guys did a great job
congratulations I mean for what I've
seen it's pretty spectacular and
bringing the book to life it was what's
I think special about the book for for
myself and it's probably true for a lot
of astronauts is the relevant topics and
they're the things that are very real
for us we all have visions of exploring
space and eventually getting to Mars and
going beyond and so for me what was
great about what's great about the book
and the end the movie that we've seen is
that it really brings those things to
life and they're very relevant for us
now so I want to thank you guys for
making us look good I mean where I
worked I don't know we're not as smooth
and cool as what we see on the screen
and even in the book but at least you
give us a chance to look in public so
thanks for that there's an hour and a
quarter the ghosts so there's a lot to
see and Andy for you talked a little bit
about this before but you know I'm so
curious what the this journey has been
you know it has been rather quick even
just since the original ebook was
published but now that this has already
happen - what is the journey been like
for you oh it's been this just
ridiculous like cinderella story I mean
like you fantasize about these kinds of
things when you're writing but you never
really think they'll come true it's kind
of like when you're a little kid playing
baseball you're like someday I'm gonna
be a bottom of the ninth in the World
Series but it's like this actually
happened I saw I saw I saw the full cut
of the film on Friday and I got to say
like I love it
and Matt you you completely nailed the
character like it is exactly how I
imagined Watney so you know thanks for
that and predicta green for true I'm
kind of curious you know how you know
sci-fi films like this you know kind of
I don't know a reflector work at NASA
and also you know the kind of bring it
to life in a way and
do you think that that what do you think
audiences can kind of take from that as
well well you know science fiction is
extremely important in our culture it's
ingrained in what we do but it really
projects a vision of the future
something that we aspire to and what I
really enjoyed about the book in the
movie is how close to reality it can be
it's just around the corner for us you
know when things that we haven't
invented that we see in the movie it's
engrained in our mind and we project
that and we want to develop that that's
how it will look and that's really
exciting and we all have a part to play
when we do things like that I think we
want to open it up to questions if
people can maybe raise their hands I
think we have mics going around yes is
any questions from right here this is
for Ridley Scott did you make any
decision to on Mars shoot it like it's
gravity did you talk about trying to
portray more Mars gravity and that was
too difficult are you an expert how much
do you know I mean it bosses 40 percent
right so by the time fairly chunky suit
even the surface suit not just the big
weights there appears in the end is very
heavy so we worked out the mathematics
roughly it's kind of more or less just
under Norment so that's where we made a
decision so with the run right I think
in a situation like that you just kind
of have to suggest it you know I mean
you can't ever we're not at the plate
where we can do 40% gravity I mean we
can do weightless you know we know how
to we can do we can do we can get on
wires and we do all that for the space
stuff where we're all that we're all on
wires or you could do you can do the you
know the the yeah the vomit comet you
you know you can do that and and and do
weightless for 20 seconds or whatever
but but but for real scene work like we
do at the end you know it's all
wires we're still doing what we did 40
years ago but for doing kind of 40% the
gravity it's just you can only suggest
it I think yeah it looks great
wake him up is that something you it's
it's it's like I think it's a it's the
illusion that I carry the movie it's
actually Alden hunter Ridley you know it
really is you know and and and I'll get
a lot of the credit for what for what he
did because it's it's he's got to keep
the audience with just one actor up
there he's got to keep them involved and
keep the story going and it really was
the reason I wanted to do it you know I
read the script I thought it was great I
read the book I thought it was great and
and but when I heard Ridley wanted to do
it that was the you know it's a
director's medium what I do and and and
and when you get one of the greatest
directors of all time it's just a very
very quick phone call and and and then
yeah was a chance I said okay well it's
gonna be me you know in a lot of these
scenes but it's but it's gonna be me and
really you know and that's a very easy
decision to make
actually the first day we worked we sort
of kind of first monologue it was a
couple pages and I did one take and he
came bounding onto the set and he goes
we should shoot two movies at once
hi I'm Cassandra I'm a journalist for
the Los Angeles Times High School in
Center and this question is for mr.
Damon mark points out that he is low on
the ladder that he is you know the 18
person to step on Mars and while he
doesn't shift in perspective and the way
he sees himself he's sort of odd at the
celebrity and attention he's received
from back at home so did your
perspective for yourself every shift in
your moments of celebrity no I'm an
actor so the astronauts are very
selfless they're thinking of the bigger
project the actors you just want to look
at themselves
totally different animal I think I'm
next
hi Matt I'm Julie Chang with Good Day LA
I think I'm yeah over here uh waving how
eager and excited are you to inspire a
future generation of scientists with
this movie well it's funny you know Drew
Goddard who adapted the screenplay when
I sat and talked with him it was the
first thing he said he said this is a I
want this to be a love letter to science
and and I thought and we had a long
conversation about that and how that's a
really wonderful thing to put out into
the world right now and and and yeah I
hope I you know I I don't have you know
any lofty expectations but I do hope
that some some kids see it and get and
and and and geek out on the science and
enjoy it and and and and maybe maybe
it's one thing in many other things in
their life that might push him in that
direction you know I really think that
that indeed will happen you know we're
talking about the Mars generation you
know Ridley and I and and true perhaps
were around when we landed on the moon
and we were the lunar generation that
was pretty spectacular but when we
landed curiosity on Mars we had the
world's attention and that's the Mars
generation that's the inspiration that
will propel our economy forward by
bringing in the scientists and the
engineers and in the movie in the book
is a fabulous opportunity for really us
to celebrate that hi this is for Matt
hey this is like the second time
recently that you've been trapped in
space just wondering would you go into
space if you had the opportunity this is
something you would want to do and
anything your family would feel about
that you know but I'd ask drew all about
it no I
yeah I've I've done a lot of space
travel in the last couple years on
screen and and and and no I I think I
would I think but I do think you have to
be a certain type of person I mean like
the
pioneers were the view know the people
who crossed Death Valley in a wagon I
mean you know it takes a special type of
person to want to push the envelope to
find where the very edges and go there
and and and that's how that's how you
know that's how we evolve that's how we
you know we that's why we're here you
know on the west coast so so yeah I
think that takes a special type of
person I'm glad that there are those
types of people already but you know I'm
I think I think it would be it would be
tough for me to do it maybe I'll let
SpaceX and those guys get out there you
know for like maybe 20 years or so
before I take a before before I go on a
flight oh it's a good one for drew you
know involved in the program and and the
training I would say that we're choosing
astronauts to go to Mars every time we
have an astronaut selection and the idea
is that as we continue on in this legacy
of space exploration each class that we
choose in NASA selects a class every two
to five years really the goal is to
continue to select astronauts that we
think are capable and qualified to go to
space and if they're not the ones they
would be there they are going to be
involved in the planning and preparation
and training the next generation of
astronauts so in reality we've been
selecting astronauts to go to Mars since
we started the space program and we
continue to do that the actual selection
is really a function of when we have our
spacecraft ready and that's going to
take some time we still have some
technical technological hurdles to get
over but the intent is for us to
continue to develop those explore and be
ready within the next you know I think
every year that passes every step we get
closer to our Orion spacecraft being
completed for deep-space exploration
that just enables us to look at
additional technologies and figure out
what it's going to take to go a little
bit farther to Mars we've been to Mars
robotically obviously for us humans are
next and we just continue on that
journey with with every passing year
with an
space program I can do a follow-up those
who are submitting very and BMS
character very psychologically strong is
it a major as I said I mean that's
basically who we select any mission that
we carry out in space requires some
level of psychological stability you
know it's a funny thing about astronauts
we have to be smart enough to fly a
spacecraft back to earth but just a
little bit wacky enough to sit on top of
that rocket fuel so you know we're all a
little bit Six Sigma in some way or
another that allows us to take that trip
and you know when the countdown gets to
zero you're definitely having second
thoughts about the decisions you make in
your life to get there but you get there
and you go there and and for us it's
just about you know doing the job that
we were trained to do and and carrying
out the mission hi everybody I'm trace
from Discovery News we cover science and
stuff for youths on YouTube when it
comes to recently there was lettuce
eating in space which is very cool and
the botany part is a big part of this
movie so I thought maybe the science
guys could speak a little bit to growing
crops in Martian soil and if that's a
viable like is that fiction where is
that nonfiction these days well you know
well since curiosity has landed on Mars
and it's interrogated the area that it's
at and it's sitting in an ancient
riverbed and where the water flowed for
tens maybe a hundreds of millions of
years and in the water it seems to have
been drinkable and so this is a fabulous
area and and now we've looked at the
soil we've examined it
it actually has nitrates and and more
nitrogen and that's great for fertilizer
we see from curiosity that there's more
humidity than we expected and that means
the soils also got more humidity other
than the perchlorates which indeed are a
hazard some things will grow in that
some things won't the Martian soil will
require some additional material as is
shown in the movie and in the book but
sometimes the soil here on earth so I
don't think that's a just a stumbling
block as we think anymore it's now a
matter of how to be able to do that
the area the size what we can grow we
need to do more experiments in those
areas and that's what we did it's
station you know the you know using
hydroponics and and growing the romaine
lettuce that's that's those are all
important steps and the research is
being done you through Johnson Space
Center I'll just say that you know so I
wrote the Martian and it was done and it
was set I couldn't make any changes
around the time curiosity landed and so
in the Martian you see mark Watney right
there do all this stuff to generate
water on Mars just this huge hassle that
he goes through you know reducing
hydrazine blowing himself up all that
stuff like that then curiosity a little
pain in the ass goes down to Mars and it
samples the soil and finds out that for
every cubic meter of Martian soil
there's about 35 liters of water trapped
in it so all you had to do was you know
bring some dirt inside and heat it up
well in addition to that you know we've
really looked at the water resources on
Mars and it has a significant amount of
water we believe there's underground
aquifers we fact we we actually believe
we've seen now a very glacier and so
indeed we used to think we're going to
bring all our water with us and now all
we can tell the astronauts is well bring
your straw because we really know where
to go and what to do right here G Andra
LaBeouf black sports online over here
this question is for the author mister
where Andy weir what do you think it was
about this particular project that
resonated with your initial audience and
garnered the attention of the people who
are creating it well the initial
audience I mean we're all like hardcore
geeks because I'd been writing
science-based
like humor stuff for about 10 years
earlier so my kind of mailing list was
full of people who really liked stories
where you show your work it never
occurred to me that it would have any
mainstream appeal but I think what
people really like is they just like the
snarky smartass attitude of the main
character and you know that came as a
total surprise to me I really thought it
would be this complete niche thing that
very few people would be interested in
my favorite thing is I love it is when I
get fan mail and it says like I don't
usually read science fiction but
and then goes on to say nice things
about the book so question for Ridley
over here on your on your left or at
least the the aspect of the humor I mean
what was great in the book and what you
can see from Drew is the humor because
it brings out the humanity can you talk
about balancing and finding that tone
because it's an interesting thing to
walk and write stuff did it you're right
but can you talk about finding that yeah
well I mean that's the relationship
between what I do it and the actor and
we discussed quite in-depth about the
fact that the story had to be told to a
certain extent with quite a lot of
voiceover right and in it right there in
effect that's a challenge format because
otherwise voice-over could easily become
elongated and boring and I think in this
I think he succeeded brilliantly by
incorporating humor sometimes changing
demeanor because I think we invented the
GoPro because the GoPro became his only
companion on board that what he's in the
habitat with his in the the rover
he's always talking when he's talking to
somebody in a like he's always talking
to a buddy because I figured in that
habitat and there'll be 50 GoPros
wherever you go the goal for in a funny
kind of way logically is like the black
box if something went wrong you'd want
to know why and when and how it happened
okay so the the GoPro became the
companion but I think you have to hand
it to Matt I think we have time for one
more in the mics right there
hi James darling a science versus cinema
a question for sir Ridley the film's
release date got actually moved up two
months which kind of echoes the sort of
accelerated deadline the scientists of
the story face I was just curious how
that affected you and your team of
filmmakers
I was curious yeah you're dead lying
about the movie about two weeks after we
shot the next movie dude
but Northshore looked locations the next
movie but I just put me sister fantasy
there Mike out there tomorrow ah the
with the one watch time well that
probably would have been handy but no I
mean we we connected with really just
called everybody takes Ridley's call and
if you curious about my research process
it was Google I didn't know anyone in
aerospace when I wrote it in fact I was
coming back from the cafeteria when our
public affairs official came by running
around looking for me and he comes up to
me and he says uh can you take a call
with Ridley Scott at two o'clock this
afternoon and I said the Ridley Scott
and he said yeah I said sure so I just
cleared my calendar I mean that's it's
that easy the studio's okay Michael I
think that's all the time we have so
thank you so much everybody
you